all right everybody i wasn't even
necessarily going to stream today and
then i was later and then i saw how
insane what's going on is with johnny
depp's business manager so let's jump
right in no songs no nothing i'm gonna
get set up while we watch
he didn't have enough money at the time
correct he was spending more than he was
bringing in correct
yes
and you gave him advice about how he
could hopefully get out of that problem
correct
yes okay and
just to be clear
uh mr white because you've testified to
to some degree of knowledge about
um
wine that you you you allege that miss
heard requested so you seem to have some
some knowledge of of mr depp's spending
miss her didn't she didn't buy any of
the dozens of properties that mr depp
owned correct
correct he owned the assets prior to
their marriage she didn't pay five
million dollars to blast hunter
thompson's ashes out of a cannon did she
not to my knowledge she didn't buy a
yacht that she couldn't afford and then
have to sell it to jk rowling did she
not to my knowledge
now let's talk about that meeting on
april 21st 2016. you said the meeting
started it's about 7 30 p.m
yes and lasted until maybe 9 30 is that
right yes
and you have no idea
no personal knowledge where mr depp went
after he left that meeting do you
that is correct i did not go with him i
went home
and at that meeting
mr depp was given some catastrophic news
about his business correct
he was given news that he needed to
address a number of financial issues but
i had a strategy and plan to fully
resolve them
that news that he was given that night
was catastrophic wasn't it
no
may i approach your honor all right yes
sir
so if you're just joining us this is the
business manager of johnny depp
now under cross-examination by amber
heard's attorney
riveting stuff
mr white let's do this again with
another
under oath series of statements you gave
testimony in the uk trial did you not
yes
and that testimony was under oath
correct yes all right and in front of
you i have your testimony from the uk
trial and you gave that testimony on
behalf of mr depp correct
i gave it honestly okay
you gave it on behalf of mr depp
correct you were one of his witnesses
called that is correct okay can you
please turn to page 865.
this may not go that well for this guy
it's just the second page of the
document upper left before that the
questions are talking about this meeting
on april 21st 2016
and you were asked the question question
now mr depp was given some catastrophic
news about his business answer
that is correct
did i read that right
you did but remember uh that was just a
chance to answer my question sir i did
not define that sir mister you'll have a
chance the attorney will get back up and
redirect you okay so if you just answer
his question that's fine and the reason
i'm asking sir is because you just gave
the exact opposite testimony here so
that's what that's why we pointed that
out
um now you at this meeting you had a
discussion about his financial affairs
and a necessity to formulate a revised
business strategy and plan correct yes
and you talked about the following
financial information you talked about
bank obligations and tax liabilities
right yes which means money you owe to
either the government or banks correct
yes
you talked about assets that he needed
to sell correct yes properties and
things like that that he needed to sell
to generate money
correct
you talked about ways to reduce spending
correct
yes
and you talked about
how to get new engagements
correct
yes how to get new gigs right
not how to get them but then i encourage
you to get them
i'm not an agent i appreciate that
curious engagement
and understood
you talked about the need to
get new gigs to generate additional
money to help
uh address these financial woes that he
was experiencing correct yes
you also told him at that meeting that
um
his taxes he hadn't paid taxes in years
correct
no that's not correct that he had not
paid any taxes in years is not correct
that that
he was significantly delinquent in
federal tax obligations dating back
years correct
i don't know how you're defining years
there were delinquent liabilities i
addressed them
and formulated a plan
i am curious how this will be used to
support or fight against defamation
allegations
welcome to everyone on twitch yes we
have a hype train i know
and you talked about these significant
delinquent tax liabilities that would
run into the millions of dollars for
taxes unpaid correct that is correct
and so after receiving these this
catastrophic news as we discussed you
have no idea where mr depp went when he
walked out of the doors of his office
correct
i do not know where he went can you pull
up plaintiff's exhibit 936 please oh
oh boy
and mr white i'm not gonna
this is a long a long document
that we can we can scroll through but
what i'll i'll
represent to you and
michelle can sort of scroll down is that
these these appear to be
mr depp's tax returns for mr death and
his companies from 2009 to 2019 do you
see that
yes
and
these are our returns as part of your
role as his cpa
firm now his business manager firm now
you your firm prepares these tax returns
correct yes and you maintain these tax
returns in the ordinary course of your
business correct that is correct your
honor i know there's going to be plenty
of redaction to do but i just would like
to move these into evidence i don't plan
to publish them or anything at this
point
objection
so we are back to in-person testimony
and uh this this uh this is quite a
character i don't know if i'd put him up
there with the butler but certainly
a notable uh and titillating character
in this entire thing
uh so far many of you have written to me
and you you've observed
apparently what some of you are
describing is a flirtatious regular
interaction between
this attorney to johnny depp's left and
johnny depp um and that i have to be
perfectly frank i haven't noticed that
in particular but
kind of i guess maybe interesting to
some people
um
and otherwise the trial continues now
remember that this is all the depth case
later it will be the amber herd case and
i can only imagine what's going to
happen there i have to tell you with all
the horrible things going on
there's something endlessly entertaining
about this trial that is not correct
are you familiar with tracy jacobs
yes
that's mr mr depp's uh former agent
correct
yes and at the time that she was serving
as his agent part of her job
responsibilities to the best of your
understanding was to communicate with
you about mr depp's financial affairs
correct
to the extent she had knowledge
right yes she would communicate and and
you and she did communicate about uh mr
depp correct
during the period of engagement yes we
did communicate
can you pull up defendants exhibit 874
please michelle
mr white do you
do you see here this text exchange
between you and tracy jacobs
yes and your texts are in in white and
miss jacobs are in blue correct
yes
michelle could you please scroll to um
the document that that
is bait stamped dep19246
it's about the fifth or sixth one down
please
mr white do you see here the third text
down from tracy jacobs to you
um
saying thanks i got a call from disney
last week saying he showed up objection
it's not hearsay it's party opponent
she's his agent we've i'm happy to
approach if you'd like to discuss
we seem to have seeds and nuts being
chewed by uh johnny depp he has been uh
sometimes offering seeds and nuts to his
attorneys
which is interesting to say the least
uh i want to say thank you to some great
people who have been re-upping twitch
prime subscriptions including billy
carpenter dustin iriman and brain matter
very much appreciate that i will be live
with the trump rally tomorrow evening
yes i hope many of you will join me
it'll be a little bit of a later stream
trump goes live at nine p east so i will
be live at 8 p east
and that'll be
some people say it's
the perfect time for people who want to
see the full interview with trump as
candidate john gibbs that i previewed
yesterday it is now live on my other
youtube channel that's the
other youtube channel pacman live the
full
and folks when i say full i mean
completely unredacted
23-minute interview with trump's
candidate john gibbs it's now live on
the pacman live youtube channel already
getting some very nice emails about it
i see
hoosier deez
in twitch chat
is finding it scintillating
um
yeah it is i mean he just he didn't
answer any questions
i was like okay sure gas prices are high
but like do you agree that they are down
from their peak
he's like
i believe they are too high right so do
i but
just so we can get to my next question
are we on the same page that they're
down he goes they're way too high
right right but it was it was it was
crazy
it was endless
uh what else do we have going on
there's a lot i can't even keep up with
everything going on
thanks to kevin gouldy for gifting a
subscription so generously on my website
that subscription goes to
uh let me see who's next here sorry
michael beachler michael beachler you
get a membership thanks to kevin gouldy
i really appreciate that also thanks to
jen here for gifting a subscription on
twitch that's always appreciated
uh what do i think is going on with
twitter follows yeah a bunch of right
wingers getting followers and a bunch of
left wingers like me losing followers
since the
announcement of elon musk buying twitter
was announced to be totally honest i
don't have an explanation right now
could it be organic
i i really don't know i genuinely don't
know i gave my opinions yesterday
of what we know at the time
and then we'll you know hopefully there
will be more information coming
22 demo22
has uh grabbed the twitch prime
subscription and is number seven very
much appreciate that thank you to
everybody come on in everybody we're in
the middle of testimony this is the
cross-examination of johnny depp's
business manager edward white we're
watching it closely it's pretty
entertaining it's it's pretty wild and
right now they're arguing about a
particular text conversation which makes
johnny depp look really bad there's no
doubt about it being regularly late to
filming and all of these other things so
we'll see where they're going with this
how is my espresso today good good a
beautiful crema today i think i've got
it really dialed in
susie d has just grabbed the twitch
prime subscription in his number eight
today thank you also aza
is a new twitch prime subscriber and
slingblade as well slingblade a very
very powerful
shot across the bow there
sam cedar is back on his show recovered
from the virus we're glad to see him
back of course of course i was in touch
with sam
uh
urgently in touch with him
throughout his illness
i also want to say thanks to jody
bundrick jody has just gifted a
subscription on my website that's number
11. the lucky recipient
is
robin
mace
robin mace
if you'd like a free membership you can
register at davidpakman.com
free membership there are currently
692 people in line ahead of you just
bear that in mind but we are getting
through a whole bunch i think in total
we've gifted about
230 website memberships roughly would be
my guess
somewhere in there
do we have any other
trumpist interviews coming up my
colleague john is working on that yeah
i've been enjoying it's so funny because
the the inter this is crazy but the
interviews with trumpists are basically
dementia screening
it questions like i say to them who's
the president
and what's crazy is none of them can
just answer correctly i mean it's it's
bizarre that we've gotten to this point
but i'm the trumpest candidates are so
bonkers
that we we ask questions often asked to
people where we're trying to see did you
have a stroke or do you have a brain
injury do you have dementia
it's it's wild it really is wild
none scheduled but my colleague john is
working on it pixelninja has just
subscribed via twitch prime and is
number 12 today thank you i really
appreciate that pixel ninja
am i on truth social i am not i don't
have an iphone so i just i don't know
i can't get on there
on the friday show tomorrow we're going
to look at a republican candidate who
says her son saw jesus in a closet and
that's why she's running you remember
that text yes okay we're going to just
going to show you
uh and move for admission of that that
page of the document with that text um
so i just wanted since you won't see
anything else i just wanted you to
orient yourself that that is the text
that we were just reading okay
fine
you're right
that page or that text we're going to
redact you just that one text thank you
your honor i would move for admission of
this document as i guess we could call
it
defendants874a okay 874 a with the
redactions all right thank you
mr white um you you just testified uh a
few minutes ago that you you didn't have
any understanding of mr depp showing up
late for work on pirates five but in
fact you received this text from tracy
jacobs that says thanks
i got a call from disney last week
saying he showed up five hours late for
adr work in london for pirates five i
really need to speak to him before he
starts work on his net next project in
la did i read that right
permission to publish this your honor oh
yes i'm sorry thank you
adr is automated dialogue replacement
presumably re-recording some lines of
films i'll ask you if i if i read that
right that you received this text
message saying in part i got a call from
disney last week
saying he showed up five hours late for
adr work in london for pirates five i
really need to speak to him before he
starts work on this next project in la
did i read that right
i believe you blend it right thank you
now
at some point you became familiar
you can go ahead and take that down
thank you at some point you became
familiar as you testified with what
amber planned to do with money that she
got from mr deaf in the divorce correct
it was the understanding from the
beginning the money would be contributed
to charities the two
charities children's hospital
children's hospital of la
and the aclu correct
that is correct and as we discussed you
wrote checks to those two organizations
that were part of
mr depp's divorce payment but they were
just sent directly to those
organizations correct
yes can you please pull up
defendants exhibits
1639 actually let's do
let's do defendants exhibit um
yeah we'll do one six three nine
thanks
there's water everywhere in here and i
don't even know where it came from
this is a letter from you to the aclu
foundation dated august 24th 2016.
correct
yes
and um
as as
part of your your work for your 100
or so high profile high net worth
clients you've helped clients set up
pledged contributions to charities
before correct yes
and sometimes those payments are made
over a period of time correct
yes charitable donations aren't always
paid at once correct
that is correct and when you make
payments on behalf of your clients to
charities um is it customary for you
my cover letter like this
in some instances yes and some instances
no okay but in all instances
that there is
a signed agreement and an understanding
of when the yeah that means that that
wasn't my question my question was just
is it customary for you to send a letter
like this um and i think you've answered
that and so when you send letters like
this on behalf of your clients do you do
you prepare such letters in the ordinary
course your business
in some instances yes and when you in
the instances in which you prepare those
letters do you then maintain those
letters in the ordinary course of your
business
yes your honor i'd move for admission of
defendants exhibit one six three nine
nine injection
all right 16 39 in evidence and you can
publish it to the jury thank you
and michelle if you could please just
scroll through mr white i just want you
to see there's the the letter here
um we'll come back to the letter and
then there's there's the check
that you're making out to the aclu
then there's i guess the envelope or
something right
correct okay you can go back to the
letter please
so in this in this uh
in this cover letter
you
tell the aclu that you're enclosing a
check for a hundred thousand dollars
and that the donation is being made in
accordance with ms heard's pledged gift
of three and a half million to the aclu
foundation correct
yes and you also write that the check
represents uh
just go ahead the the check represents
uh the first
of multiple scheduled installments
correct it was my understanding this is
going to contribute three million
dollars to children you've asked me a
question i'm trying to respond i was
actually just asking if that's what you
wrote
would you ask the question again yeah
you write this check represents the
first of multiple scheduled installments
to honor the full amount of ms heard's
three and a half million dollar pledge
gift it was my understanding she was
going to contribute the money and that's
okay we do have our lawyers in the
audience it would be interesting to know
whether this kind of antagonistic
condescending attitude
is considered to be
uh useful in terms of how the jury would
perceive it to me it strikes me as as
not a great strategy but he must be
doing it for a reason i'd be curious to
hear strategy on it from lawyers in the
audience
oh now they're going to be discussing an
issue
once
the herd side starts to present their
case maybe depp's lawyers will start to
take this condescending attitude i don't
know it
it's it's a curiosity for sure
thanks to black white rook and better
call saul for the twitch prime
subscriptions boy that better call saul
season six that is something i'm three
episodes in which i think is all that's
been been published so far
it is just a fantastic program it really
is
i am going to try to get a different
feed that maybe just doesn't have a
watermark this uh a letter
similar to what we just looked at for
the aclu
a letter um
that you wrote that accompanied the
check that you sent to the children's
hospital of los angeles foundation yes
and
this uh letter and the better audio
sorry this letter is one that you would
have prepared in the ordinary course of
business correct yes and you would have
maintained this letter in the ordinary
course of business correct yes um you're
on a move for the admission of exhibit
1596.
all right 1596 in evidence you can
publish it to the jury
and mr white this letter also
says at the bottom that it represents
the check that accompanies this letter
represents the first of multiple
scheduled installments to honor the full
amount of misheard's 3.5 million dollar
pledged gift correct
when i composed a letter that was my
understanding that she was going to give
three deadly servants
you're really not answering my question
my question was simply i i understand
that you you want to wanna
you wanna speak your own narrative here
but my question was simply that this
letter says that this check represents
the first of multiple scheduled
installments to honor the full amount of
misheard's three and a half million
dollar pledge gift
correct we can both read the letter and
answers yes thank you sir
now you hosted a dinner with mr depp um
and adam waldman in in 2016 correct uh
oh
i do recall that and that was the first
time that uh
mr depp had been introduced to mr
waldman correct
i do not know that the fact now
you you are not an expert on california
divorce law right correct and you're not
an expert on the division of marital
property in california correct
i'm not an expert but i've been actively
involved in numerous cases involving the
disillusionment of marriage
and the related proceeds are distributed
to each respected party
please proceed governor now you can't
give any sort of legal opinion
or testimony as to whether or not miss
heard would have been entitled to more
in the divorce settlement with mr death
than she received correct
i'm not an attorney at law okay i don't
have legal opinions
so
you've never met amber heard correct
that is correct the first time you've
ever seen her in person is here in this
courtroom this afternoon correct that's
my recollection and you have no personal
knowledge of whether mr depp engaged in
domestic abuse against my client
correct
i've never witnessed him
involved in any abuse and obviously i
have never met her i could not respond
to that inquiry so the answer to my
question is that it's correct that you
have no personal knowledge of whether mr
death engaged in domestic abuse against
amber hurt
that is correct i have no knowledge
nothing further all right redirect
oh boy mr denison
can we pull up
defendants 1596
there's probably weeks left of the trial
for people asking
sir can you read the last line of
your letter
sir
this check represents the first of
multiple scheduled installments to honor
the full amount of ms heard's 3.5
million dollar pledged gift
what was the schedule for those payments
they were scheduled i i don't know the
schedule because i don't have a copy of
any pledge that she made
if that's your question
okay thank you very much
one more question
is mr depp paid all his taxes
yes he has he's fully current with all
of this federal
uh foreign
and state tax obligations thank you
all right no further questions mr jensen
all right is this witness subject to
recall no
no
all right mr white you're free to go
thank you sir just be very careful
stepping down there okay thank you honor
thank you have a good day
wow
all right your next witness is remote
witness correct
all right
let me just
give them
might be time for a break your honor
your honor may we just ask what witness
they plan to follow i i see a mr
connolly in the lobby so i'm assuming
that must be
that must be the one
okay good
good i'm glad we got that one all right
[Applause]
[Music]
and i won't talk about the third element
of a bathroom
yeah that's probably smart
that is probably smart
i don't know what that noise is it's a
bizarre noise
oh people saying ozark tomorrow yeah you
know oh you know who follows me on
instagram who i've exchanged some
messages with
the actress jessica dukes who plays the
fbi agent in mr conley can you hear me
yes yes sir
yep hi yeah can you turn your camera on
sir
sir
okay there we go there we go this should
be interesting
all right sir if you could raise your
right hand
do you swear firm tell the truth on a
penalty of law i hope we can see him i
do all right
all right and uh good afternoon mr
connolly
good afternoon
and would you please state your full
name for the record
welcome cornell here we go and mr
connolly uh where are you testifying
from at the moment
uh from home uh essex uk
and and where do you live
i live in essex uk
mr connolly what is your occupation
uh at present um coast protection
operative
i've had a couple of professions i'm a
bricklayer trade i was in the
corrections facility could we pump him
up please hms prison
but right now yeah i'm a
officer
okay and and can you tell us a little
bit uh just generally
what that means
that means uh
looking after
the personal well-being
the physical well-being
of any client you're detailed to
and how long have you been in the
personal security business
25 years
over the course of those 25 years have
you had any other kinds of jobs
yeah as i said i was a corrections
officer for a majestic prison they
should really ask him if he uses the
term fuzzy ginger for uh for a soda are
you familiar with the plaintiff in this
case johnny depp
i am yes
and how do you know mr depp
yeah i know mr depp
a long uh maybe about
23 years ago 24 years ago
i worked for a company called music and
arts the guy who won that company was
jerry judge
uh jerry started working with johnny
way back in the early days
and i was detailed by looking after uh
johnny's ex
vanessa parity
and
jack and lily rose johnny's kids and my
my job is just to make sure they were
safe when johnny was at work
so that job
after about a year and a half two years
johnny uh asked me to go over him
directly and we'll find someone else to
do the kid doing that and that's how i
came across johnny so that's why that's
how i personally met johnny depp
can you ballpark for us about what year
that was
oh two thousand and
six
okay and can you generally just tell us
a little bit about what you do uh for mr
depp as his security guard
will knock around the photographers
to everyday uh
public
places
make sure he's okay make sure
you know he's not in any danger
first of all do the reiki you know you
go along first there's usually a two-man
team it's a two-man detail
you go along do your recce make sure all
the ins and outs are
no compromises any risks involved risk
assessment
we do the job
i look after them basically i look after
johnny whenever we're in public domain
whenever we're going to be in a public
domain
i will look after johnny
okay and uh and how about the defendant
in this case amber heard are you are you
familiar with miss heard
i am familiar with yeah
i first met miss herd in probably 2 000
and
i don't recall exactly the actual date
probably about 2010
maybe around there
she came into the uk
to do a promotional job for a movie
called drive angry
my boss johnny jerry judge asked me to
take the detail
went and met amber
started your job amber was with our ex
tosh tasha
and uh
i looked after amber for a week tash
pleasant week it was fine great
uh does anything
sorry yeah
after that week uh i never seen
amber again until we did the rum diaries
the premier uh after show where i'm
dying
the subtitles are not keeping up with
this guy's accent it's it's pretty
pathetic the the rum diary then uh when
did you see miss heard um well how did
you see ms hurd in connection with
uh the rum diary
um we were
we've done the rum daily premiere we
went to the after show party
uh
you know i'm busy working doing my job
myself and jerry judge
they died of crimea oh my god the
subtitle said that they died of crimea
which i've never it's not in the dsm-5
it doesn't seem to be a physiological
condition usually chit-chat you check
chatty for a minute or two
uh johnny asked me who actually knew
amber
explained uh that's the last sport
camera that night i was too busy
doing my job you know
did you know at the time and uh well
let's back up for a second where was
that premiere
um you know what i don't recall
i think it was
i think it was an l.a
okay i don't know
okay
did you know at the time of that uh
premiere in
probably la but possibly somewhere else
um did you know at the time that mr depp
and miss heard were seeing each other
romantically
no i didn't i actually didn't i mean i i
surmised that
there was a spark there you know that
wasn't until uh
maybe
maybe a
few days later a few nights later
we
well at a dinner party somewhere a
promotional thing
and
amber and johnny were basically you know
sparking sparking out they were looking
for getting together then i i
assumed that you know there was a
romance happening there budding there
you know
okay over the course of
mr depp and mr heard's relationship with
each other
about how often would you say you saw
them together
well in the beginning actually not a lot
you know not a lot uh
maybe once a week yeah
twice a week i push
but then it started uh well it started
maturing into something in their
relationship
so
more often
more often the changement on you know
and just as time went on did you have an
opportunity to observe uh how mr depp
and mr interacted with each other
uh at the beginning um oh you know
lovey-dovey everything was great the
honeymoon period was on and there was a
yeah it was good i mean it was great
great to see johnny happy again amber
was you know
lovely charming
as she usually is you know
good as gold
and then things you know things started
to change amber started to change amber
started
getting a bit i would say a bit more
uh feisty uh demanding you know
i could see that amber wanted to wear
the pants in this relationship that was
pretty obvious
and
what in particular made you think that
that you observed personally
um just just the way uh
you know if something wasn't quite right
or
uh
amber could uh amber could get a bit
frosty at the drop of a hat
so as time went on you know i could see
them
i could see them change i could see i
could see amber change i could see
johnny getting quieter
uh you get into the car and nobody was
speaking
and you know it's just things started
changing amber started getting a bit
more
grumpy
how did she uh how did she get along
with you
absolutely fine i i uh
amber was
fine with me
amber was never anything but
professional polite
with me you know she was uh no amber was
finding me
did you ever uh
see or hear
any arguments between mr depp and miss
hurt
uh
when you say see
i heard i mean i could hear at times and
certain accommodations would be staying
out
i could hear
amber yeah screaming you know
i could hear shouting and balling and
yeah i could hear it going on yeah
but i mean i wasn't there every sit
every single night when we
were working in the uk
those nights maybe i'd get home
because jerry would be there
but yeah yeah i did hear yeah definitely
for a fact i would i could hear
sometimes the shouting and bowling you
know it's most mostly i could hear amber
screaming you
know about how
i recognized this was years ago but can
you can you estimate for us how
regularly that happened
uh
i can't say regularly i can't say it's
like every day
but you know it get more regular got
more more often than not
did you ever uh
did you ever witness any physical
violence
between the two of them no no
no never i've never seen any physical
violence
it's not a thing
it's not a thing people would do in
front of security it's not a thing that
would it would happen in front of myself
or jerry judge or sean better some it
just wouldn't happen
it wouldn't happen
no i never seen any physics physical
security i've never seen any hands-on no
okay what do you mean you never saw any
hands-on
well i never seen any slapping or
grabbing or
punching or hitting
i've never seen any of that physically i
said well
well i'll tell you what there was like
an instance maybe
two instances that come in my mind one
incident was on a a private plane
uh i can't recall it was a domestic
flight or an international flight
i'm sitting
johnny in amber or johnny whoever he's
flying with will sit up at the four
tables the four table
up aft
and
myself
and my colleagues will sit down
the
forward end of the plane so i i usually
look up this fuselage that way
with my back to the nose
amber had her back to me johnny's
sitting across the table
and there's a bickering going on i can't
hear because you know you talk about jet
craft i can't actually hear and it's
more animated than verbal
and uh
i see it i see a later a plastic lighter
bounce off his chest boom bounce no
bounce off his chest
so right away i think well this this is
one of the escalators
see they're going to go one way or the
other
i don't think it can be much
uh
i remember johnny just us you know
smirking and looking away as if to say
you know well is that it
cannot kind of attitude you know
and johnny johnny touch his heart puts
his head against the window and
whoa
i'm out you know
uh another time
they're gonna need to get an interpreter
for some of the scottish dialect
the security room in the loft apartments
with a security guard called
do you know what i can't recall if it
was sean bay i've got a guy called
donovan
anyway i got the text i would donate to
pick him up to go to
the west hollywood
accommodation
and uh
i've got the text objection to the to
the extent he's going to talk about what
the text is that's hearsay
uh
you can just tell us what you observed
without looking at that without
recounting the contents of the text okay
okay i'm instructed to go and get johnny
and because we're leaving
jack objection he just he just said what
he was instructed to do all right i'll
just i'll sustain the objection
what did you do after you received the
text
i go to the
the loft apartment
uh the doors are just slightly just like
just a we call a crack in the door
push the door open and i go and
i can't really i can't hear i mean i'm
in the wrong area of the apartment
but as i turn as i turn to the left into
this the mode of the lounge area
there's a soda can like i i don't know i
don't know if it's a coca-cola or soda
right or i don't know what it was a
fuzzy gingerbread it's launched from the
mezzanine
and johnny's uh
had this huge tv
the biggest tv i've ever seen before but
this and it's on this mechanical arm
which is an actual piece of artwork that
johnny had
got commissioned
and anyway this this big mechanical arm
holds this tv
so this kind of pop you're going to call
it pop
smash is on that i'm about to four or so
dad because it means a bang boom
and now i can hear is that spraying all
over the place
johnny has already got his jacket on and
a bag over his shoulder
that's why he's called me in because
we're leaving
i just pick up the other bags two bags
pick up the two bags put my hands
through johnny's armor series thoughts
for leaving we walk out the door we walk
out the door and we go
halfway to
to the
west hollywood
johnny's already calm down you know he's
like man
objection objection to the extent he's
talking about what mr depp is saying all
right i'll sustain that objection to
continue uh
if you if you have uh
i i think we can move on okay all right
[Laughter]
uh just just to clarify um mr connolly
when uh
when the soda can was launched from the
mezzanine
where was mr depp in relation to where
the soda can land
10 feet 10
uh maybe 10 feet back from that 10 feet
back from that
okay and just to make sure we're on the
same page when you refer to the loft
departments uh what are you referring to
the downturn really eastern building
okay
um
what was your did you form any
understanding as to where um
as to who had thrown the soda can
um objection speculation okay hold on
sir let's speculate a second foundation
what if he died if he formed an
understanding and he can state the basis
for that
if he did if you want to lay a
foundation did you did you uh to your
knowledge was miss heard present in the
apartment at the time objection leading
yes
i never seen her physically was she
present
and and where did her could you tell
where her voice was coming from
upstairs or just upstairs
okay she wasn't on the lord the lower
apartment with us so i can only imagine
she was up to
other than the uh
other than the
cigarette lighter and the soda can
anything else similar to that you
observed
no no i can't say no no
did you ever observe any physical
injuries on this hurt
never no
how about i muster down
yeah
yes
yeah it started off with maybe a
a scratch once in a while uh you know uh
a swelling but it get got more it got
more yeah i'm not talking it was marked
every every week or every two weeks but
yeah
he he he sustained marks there
definitely he was getting married
and can you describe for us
what you can
yeah um
objection you're on a queen kind of
performance okay all right hold on mr
connolly for a minute
all right
understandably amber heard lawyers don't
like this line of questioning my guess
that i would my guess is that they're
going to argue that it's all very
speculative
and
you know later
her attorneys could say
when you saw scratch do you have any
reason to believe that it was a result
of something she did
i couldn't say is it possible that he
walked through a pricker bush yes it's
possible is it possible that he fell
down
yes it's but you know i mean it's
let's see where this goes now
uh so mr connolly you can you can
continue uh responding i think the
question was just can you generally
describe for us what you remember about
the the marks you saw on mr depp
yes
uh
as i was saying
any prison service you're taught to
uh
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away was most of
these maps and most of these things
through my training
is happening in the left-hand side of
his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe on his
billy's left ear some changed would be
two two marks two lines two charms
one
yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more now
if it's on johnny's right side does that
suggest whoever did it is left-handed is
that the understanding here um
plaintiffs exhibit 162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i i assume you can see it
on your screen he said johnny's left
side oh i misheard that
misheard
can you just quickly tell us what what
this picture is
this picture is a
miss head and johnny's
honeymoon
on the origins breath
on the east line
from
bangkok
to singapore
you travel through malaysia stop the
kuala lumpur and a few other places in
the way down and that is in the
the dining coach i think yeah dining
coach that's where that is the guy on
the left there with a silver band around
his he's the waiter he's the waiter with
the detail to look after us
the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager mister
let's just hold on one second um before
we continue describing the document i'd
move for the admission of plaintiff's
trial exhibit 162 and that it be
published to the jury any objection i'd
like to go i'd like to approach it okay
all right so attorneys will approach
again and discuss this particular
document
i want to say a big thank you to alison
neeson that's not nielsen that's neeson
who just gifted a subscription on my
website that subscription goes to
david batello david is uh getting a free
membership
you too can get one
all right and mr connolly i apologize
for cutting you off but could you just
continue to describe for us uh what
we're looking at in this picture there
it is
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager he was
detailed to which you know
fixes up anything we needed
you know to excursions and
transports and stuff then it's misheard
the guy that's the chef he looked after
this he looks he cooked for his
great chef by the way uh
great chef
and that's johnny and i also notice if
you look at that picture
like i said
on the left hand side under his eye
there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the
left-hand side of his nose and under his
left eye huh
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do what down what do i interpret as
that's uh
he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
can you tell us anything and we can take
this down i think
wow thank you
mr connolly can you tell us uh now
what's fascinating is sometimes p uh i
walked into a door as a euphemism for
someone punched me miss heard went on
their honeymoon uh in the picture we
were just looking at
um
that was
it i don't know 2013
2013
okay and were you uh well you testified
that you took the picture so you were
there i assume
absolutely yes
um
what can you tell us about that trip
generally and particularly focused on
how mr depp and ms heard were
interacting with each other
um started off good started off good uh
johnny's cabin was maybe
15 meters down the corridor from maine
there was no cabins in between
there was a like storerooms like you
know blankets was this on a boat or a
car
so i'm sorry a boat or a train rather
well not a big massive distance but you
know it wasn't neck to me
the this trip started flying absolutely
fine
i think there's five six days five days
maybe
uh
i can see johnny going down i can see
him coming down you know
he's just he's just not enjoying this
he's not enjoying us
but you know i can't it's not my
business to to step in than that i just
do my job but i can see he's not
enjoying this
he's just not he's not happy
he's not happy
did you ever observe any arguments
between mr deaf and misheard in this
time frame
just uh not arguments but uh
some frostiness misheard uh
sort of demanded that you know we have
our own
dining cart if you like
so me doing my job i inquire to the the
guest relations guy there that you've
seen in the photograph
and he quite really tells me that you
know there's other objections objections
objection to hearsay all right i think
we can move on okay i'll stay in the
action next question
all right so mr uh
mr connolly um
well taking a step back for a minute and
changing topics slightly um
have you ever seen mr depp use any drugs
i don't think i was out of objection
yes i've seen him
smoke marijuana
uh
i had my suspicions i have my suspicions
that when he goes off to the bathroom he
he probably does about
cocaine i've never seen him do it as mr
depp would never do
a line or anything like cocaine in front
of me no lines
or sean better anybody mr
johnny depp would never compromise my my
license my position
and embarrassed me like that it wouldn't
happen
so to answer to your question i've seen
him smoke weed yes
he noticed any particular
what changes if any have you noticed in
his behavior when he's under the
influence of marijuana
um
to be honest
a bit more a bit more
relaxed no sort of tight but he i mean
he's
he's not he's not an obvious line of
questions
he's perfectly functioning he would go
crazy on the pot like of course not
conversation you want to talk about he's
neither up nor down with that you know
he really isn't he's got a very high
tolerance for any substance johnny you
know i would say so you know
i think jack sparrow's more drunk than
johnny depp
[Music]
so okay so that's that's uh marijuana
what about alcohol same question
um
he likes well he used to like a wine
and the last the last um i would say the
last
couple years that's dropped drastically
as well let's say
in my last year with johnny it's quite
actually rare now
it's not rare but
he's not he's not a big boozer now he's
not a businessman
you know
i think i've seen john in the 25 20 odd
years of him with johnny i think i've
seen him drunk twice wow and but when i
say drunk i mean drunk
other than that
there's not a lot of difference in
johnny's demeanor of behavior
well you're drinking alcohol or a
smoking weed you know
okay
and and finally uh
same ques same question for the time
periods when you
formed the suspicion that he was under
the influence of cocaine
sorry what was that sorry could you ask
me that again what changes in his
behavior if any
did you observe on those occasions when
you suspected but didn't know for sure
that he was under the influence of
cocaine
well again
due to the training i had in
you know the
hmp prison service
it just seemed a bit uh
a bit more
i don't know
happier up
not so down you know
but i wouldn't say he's not leaping
around kicking his heels or anything
you know you pick his guitar up and he
and then he gets he gets right into his
guitar and
there's no major changes really you know
mary poppins
he's fighting you know
okay now you mentioned you traveled with
uh mr depp and miss heard on their
honeymoon um
in in on the orient express um
where else have you traveled with them
well all over the world
japan china
uh germany i've been all over the states
uh china interest not please say
hicksville that was an interesting story
uh
yeah all over the world
australia
went to australia
as far away as that
and and uh let's let's take that one at
a time hicksville you
said yeah mexico yeah um
hicksville's beautiful thank you
i remember because i remember hicksville
because it was a funky it's a real funky
place you know
is this hicksville new york or
hicksville the uk where is hicksville
anybody know johnny they've decided
they're going to go to hicksville
for uh you know a day
a day in the night i think it was
so we all off the chart the amber would
hand our friends all head off and uh
well amber traveled with johnny but our
friends all head off
uh i followed johnny wanted to drive his
own uh
beautiful big
i think there's like a chick-fil-a in
hicksville new york so i don't know
where it is i think it's a 58 i don't
know not an expert
you had to customize do you want to
drive this this this car
myself and uh his assistant at the time
nathan holmes we
use another johnny's cars and we follow
behind
we have we get to joshua tree hexville
they're stunning as you can imagine
it's done in a
very funky theme
all the caravans of different themes
oh there's a place called the hicksville
trailer palace in joshua tree california
it's a campground as well
no fair ground fortune teller head that
comes around and stuff all right there
it is johnny's and amber's caravan were
maybe about 15 meters from mine
maybe 20 years and it was that was done
in like the 1950s styles you know like
kitschy 1950s
kind of thing and the rest of the
caravans were all you know the zombies
coming out the ground and
was craziness
anyway we go there
there's a lot of beers all the booze
comes up
uh party starts well sitting around in
the sun messing around party starts
so there's loads of booze and uh
weed
and i think there's mushrooms
some psychedelic mushrooms
that's
going around
but the night gets a bit ruined as
as i'm watching exactly what's all
happening everybody's happy you know
johnny amber always happy
as
i'm watching what's happening i can see
johnny amber getting a bit animated
and they were probably about maybe 25
feet from me
so i
approach
and
i've been working with johnny that long
i don't have to really say anything i
only have to look at his face
and johnny can talk to me through his
face and then he'd say a word
so i know what's happening so
like oh and i saying hello boys
guys let's keep this private let's you
know let's start walking towards the
caravan let's you know take this away
from here
as i'm walking ahead you know just you
know going ahead
i can hear
you know bickering behind me
johnny's trying to
talk in his you know low tone you know
you know
keep keeping a bit quiet but amber's
getting a bit more but a bit more loud a
bit more
narky
you know so anyway i get them to the
caravan i put them inside
and i go to my caravan i've met people
at dinner parties who tell stories like
this and i'm like oh my god where is
this going don't see anything
until the next morning
uh
we sat around the pool
a couple of hours and uh we head back to
early
so nothing happened
what prompted you to do
do you have a lot of direct still left
in this matter uh i want
not terribly much more maybe 10
25 take our afternoon break then please
jim let's go ahead and take your
15-minute afternoon break all right and
then we'll come back and continue with
the testimony okay
we are stopping for tea or something i
guess uh the afternoon break a testimony
from mr connolly who was a security
guard
that originally worked uh with johnny
depp's family members but then
ultimately was hired directly
by um by johnny depp they will be taking
a break at this point let's take a break
lunch is here okay so that is important
for sure
the jury is exiting
i do want to say thank you to teresa fox
teresa just made a patreon pledge
just for kicks
today only
patreon pledges count triple so from 17
we go to 20
we're counting patreon triple today
which is incredible
my accountant who is not that guy that
was here representing johnny depp my my
accountant is uh
uh is a different accountant he doesn't
like this counting triple stuff but uh
we're gonna keep an eye on it for sure
amber heard's attorney coming over and
using the official move it along hand
sign so we could probably speculate as
to what that was about
okay let's check out a little bit of
that interview
that i did with the
um with the trumpet candidate john gibbs
it has now been published to the pacman
live youtube channel yesterday i think
we watched about seven or eight minutes
let's roughly pick it up there okay this
was pretty compelling stuff numbers
um what i do know is that gas prices are
still far too high one of the reasons
for that is for example shutting down
the keystone xl pipeline and totally
gutting all efforts to have american
energy independence uh so we've got to
go back and reverse those policies so
that we can be producing more of our own
uh supply which will bring prices down
okay but so let's so three different
things there you didn't answer my
question and you also made two claims
that were wrong so i'm gonna tr i'm
gonna do my best to keep keep up here so
do you agree gas prices are down about
20 from their peak two months ago
um what i agree on is that gas prices
are slightly higher than they were uh
when joe biden came into office and we
got to fix this problem and bring it
back down
do you dispute that the gas prices are
down 20
um
what i dispute is that uh gas prices are
good they're not good they're still too
high okay that's fair so
is 5 10 15 20 whatever one might be
still too high that's the point fair so
now see john you do not really care if
it's down 20 over the past couple of
months whatever but what i do care about
is way higher than it needs to be
so you made an assertion and i agree see
i mean i can very simply agree with you
you're right they're still too high see
how see how i'm very simply agreeing
with you
are you disputing just that they've come
down 20 or do or do you agree that they
have
um i try to spend time on the relevant
questions when i look at my policy and
the relevant issue here is we got to
bring the gas prices down how do you
know they have to come down more if you
won't even concede they're down 20 how
do you even know what they are
i know they're way higher than they were
when biden got in there we got to fix
that problem okay so it's it's not
sounding like you're willing to even in
good faith concede they're down 20 can
you tell me why
um i can tell you that i care about hot
gas prices because it affects everybody
especially those who are poor in working
class in the middle class as well
right i agree with you you're about i
agree with you but do you seem to be
unable to agree with me on just basic
facts it's weird let's move on to the
next thing you said which was keystone
xl is responsible for not having
keystone xl i want to make sure i know
what you're saying john
not having keystone xl is responsible
for gas prices being high is that an
accurate assessment of what you said two
minutes ago i'm certainly part of the
picture okay we do have to increase
domestic production that's the overall
point did you know that keystone xl
would not increase domestic production
because it's merely a transport method
from canada that's right yes okay and we
do stuff coming from canada as well okay
i think they get more supply in here so
if the keystone xl pipeline phase four
wouldn't increase production and you
just said what we need to do is increase
production how could it be responsible
for gas prices being high we've got to
do both obviously we've got to open up
that pipeline and also get more domestic
production
but you first said the pipeline not
being open is responsible for high
prices what i'm saying is since it
wouldn't lead to any more production how
is it affecting the prices
because we need to have more coming in
for here from everywhere whether that's
domestic production whether it's from
canada
but it wouldn't change how much is
coming in it would only change how it's
getting here
yeah and we need to have more ways of
getting it here obviously because that
will uh increase supply along with
increasing domestic production as well
but why would bringing it by pipeline
instead of truck lower the price
uh because it's more efficient
i've never read that before
[Laughter]
it's like i i don't know it's better to
bring it by pipeline
from people that know about this and
people that know that when you have that
pipeline open it's better for our for
increasing the supply
as well as increasing our domestic
production along with that okay do you
have any citations on that because i've
never heard that
um what i do have a citation on is that
gas prices are too high and we need to i
agree
i agree
okay
oh man i mean it's you know i i'm doing
the best i can but
[Music]
i'm finding myself at a bit of a log jam
because we seem to not even be able to
agree on the kind of basic facts let's
try a different topic altogether and see
if maybe we can make some headway
who's the president of the united states
right now
um joe biden is certainly the sitting
president but it looks like president
trump likely won the election um here's
a couple of factors david one uh
president trump got more votes the
second time they got the first time
there's no such thing in american
history of a president getting more
votes the second time and then losing
doesn't exist the second thing we know
that's a fact is president trump won the
bellwether counties and when he went to
bellwether county you win the presidency
with 100 predictability president trump
won those yet still lost both of those
are mathematically impossible so that
seems to indicate very strongly that
there is some
irregularities in the election results
so
you know people are concerned about this
rightfully so and so we really got it to
the bottom of it as well as increase our
election integrity going forward if we
don't have secure elections we don't
have fair elections you don't have a
democracy so this is a really big issue
we've got to address right well i agree
with your conclusion we have to have
secure elections you said that something
is an impossibility and and what you
said was an impossibility is if you get
more votes the second time than the
first
historically you win am i understanding
that that assessment
yes that's right okay um have you ever
seen things happen for the first time in
your life john
of course okay and so something happened
for the first time in november of 2020
is that fair to say we'll get to whether
it happened fairly don't let's not jump
ahead but arguably
something happened for the first time in
november of 2020 which is a sitting
president got more votes and still lost
fair it was the first time that that
happened
well there's different categories of
things that happen for the first time
okay uh there's getting into a car
accident for the first time okay uh well
guess what other people get in the car
accidents all the time so we know that
it's something that happens
you're talking about getting more votes
the second time you got first time
that's something that never happens and
so that's a different category that's
something that is almost certainly
mathematically impossible okay same
category as other things that happen for
the first time so let me give you an
example of something else during the
trump presidency that happened for the
first time and then let's see if we can
agree and then extrapolate from that
the average approval rating for donald
trump during his four years
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era would would you agree with
that and this is no matter even if you
look at a right-leaning pollster like
rasmussen which had trump higher
still on average trump's approval was
the lowest of any president in the
modern era can we agree on that fact
i might double check that but let's
assume just for argument's sake let's
assume it's fair enough so my suggestion
to you as a thinking man well-educated
everything we're talking a high level
here
given that trump's polling
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era which had never it was
unprecedented low
isn't it also possible that you would
see an unprecedented result in the
election is that possible is it possible
theoretically
no it's not possible for a president to
get 20 more votes than they got the
first time they still lose you know but
you didn't you didn't answer the
question that got 3.5 million less votes
the second time the first time he still
won okay so you're really looking at
just pure impossibilities here
i'm not so you're saying that
there's lots of things that happened for
the first time during the trump
presidency but this one thing trump
getting more votes and losing that one's
not possible
that's correct because like i said
let's see if the trial's back not yet
okay we'll keep going there's something
happening for first time that are
possible there are some that are not
why haven't any courts found any merit
to the 63 different 2020 election
related complaints that have been
brought to them many of them trump
appointed judges why why is it
because the democrats have their legal
game going in a really good way i must
say even though what they're working for
was not good um they had people like
mark elias in charge of it and they did
a good job of it our side was so to
react still to respond and did not take
this issue seriously enough before the
election that's just a sad fact i wish
it weren't true so that's answer your
question there but if there were merit
wouldn't a trump-appointed judge say
there's merit here let's proceed
well you know if you look at our side
leading up to the election when it comes
to election integrity yeah prepare well
enough uh that's just a sad fact of it
so how could you have been more prepared
there was an army of hundreds of lawyers
and trump said for six months it was
going to be rigged how could they how
could you have been what could have been
done to be more prepared
um a whole lot more you need to have
action at the state level you need to
have litigation they did watching there
was not nearly enough of that going on
he'd have pool watchers need that pull
challenger signed up
look in virginia for example at governor
juncken's election yeah typically in an
election in virginia republicans have
coverage at twenty percent of the
precincts as poll watchers okay when
governor younkin won republicans had 90
coverage at the precincts that's a
concrete example of something that the
republicans did that was smart and that
made an impact on the election and what
i'm saying and i'm suggesting here is
that we didn't have enough of that
leading up to the 2020 election which is
why you saw some of the results you did
and that carries over david as well to
the legal issues um where there's not
enough preparation very sadly so um yeah
i think
we've got to bring our a game next time
why do you think that in arizona the
audit that was done extended joe biden's
lead
um i have to go look at that a lot of
these artists they simply recounted the
existing ballots which is not we do you
want to go through and do a more
thorough look uh to see which ones
remember in arizona they were they were
looking at each ballot they were looking
for bamboo fibers barbecue sauce all
these different things well then which
ones are not etc but that being said i
need to go back and read the details
i've got to find out um exactly what
happened but
um yeah i mean we really uh got to make
sure we increase our election integrity
people are losing the faith in the
system there are people saying they're
not going to vote anymore because of
what happened so we really have got to
restore the public's confidence in our
election system you know the polling
shows that the american people are
actually very confident in our election
systems it's just some trumpists that
aren't but what indicator are you seeing
that at the national level americans
aren't confident because i just looked
at polling and americans seem very
confident and i've looked at polling
that says opposite something like over
half of all people believe that the 2020
election results were not legitimate
even a month that's not true even among
independents the number i believe was
over 50 percent no my aircraft's number
was something like in 30 to 40 range so
there's a very very significant number
of people that believe that
unfortunately there were real
irregularities in the 2020 election and
that's why we've got to restore the
public's confidence and the election
process i mean i think you know the
that's not true that that's what the
polling is in the immediate aftermath of
the election 57 percent of trump voters
believed that that number has since
declined dramatically and right now only
about 20 percent of overall americans
believe that but i think i have a
different question which is just because
of a lot of americans believe something
does that mean we change our laws for
that what's your philosophy on that
well you know i think you have a point
there david that we do what's right not
based on a popular opinion but this is
nation where popular opinion does happen
to be right i thought there were issues
and so uh like i said the results were
mathematically impossible so we've got
to look at what happened we've also got
to make sure elections are secure going
forward you know it's weird because
everybody who is saying that this was a
mathematical impossibility so i'm
hearing you say it i don't know if
you're familiar who mike lindell is he
sells pillows on television i don't know
if you've heard of him i've heard of him
yes yeah he says it's a mathematical
impossibility
sometimes lawyers who have no training
in mathematics say it's a mathematical
impossibility but then you go to actual
statisticians and they say there's
nothing here that raises any red flags
whatsoever
do you think there's some reason why
it's non-mathematicians that are
convinced about the mathematical
impossibility i'm trying to figure that
out
um i would bet that if you ask
mathematicians you will find that they
will say these are highly irregular
numbers
especially the two cases i cited you so
i believe that there are many who would
admit that these numbers are impossible
okay
um when it comes to
your platform if you were lucky enough
to win in 2022 and i know you've got to
run in a couple minutes so we'll kind of
end on this note
uh
what would be your goal with regard to
what is being threatened as an
impeachment of joe biden if republicans
take the house and you win
do you think that that's something that
the house of representatives should
prioritize the way congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene and lauren bobert
and others have said
the evidence of the evidence warrants it
absolutely if the evidence says
the policies of the biden administration
deliberately have hurt millions of
people um with recklessness and
carelessness um if we determine that
then yes it would be appropriate now
what's funny is
all the time presidents make policy
decisions and they're not always good
for everybody you know you don't impeach
presidents over them any specific policy
right now that you suspect might meet
that threshold
i think one you've got to look at the
covert response um there'd be an
investigation there uh so you've got to
look at the afghanistan withdrawal which
got americans killed
and there's also the possibility of
looking at ukraine as well and the
absolute
lack of leadership uh that's being shown
right now those are some possibilities
and as we dig into those if we find out
that there are high crimes and
misdemeanors then those need to be
pursued so you're open i know you're
saying you're not saying for sure but
you might
support impeaching joe biden
for his response to russia's invasion of
ukraine did i hear that correctly
if there's evidence that american
weakness has led to deaths especially of
americans which is not as much an issue
in ukraine but more in afghanistan as
well as on the southern border frankly
the whole southern border situation
which is human trafficking um uh is is
absolutely outrageous so if we
investigate those and we find that there
are high crimes and misdemeanors and yes
you've got a you have a constitutional
obligation
so so the four possible it's four
possible areas of biden impeachment it
was coveted afghanistan ukraine and the
border is that is it just those four are
there more perhaps there could be others
you know we'll take a look at it he
knows of at least four reasons to
impeach joe biden there could be more
see and if we find that there are high
crimes misdemeanors then we will go to
the next step wow wow uh john gibbs john
gibbs is running as a republican he's
running to unseat congressman peter
meyer that's a silent j as we we now all
know
uh john i really appreciate your time
today it's quite an eye-opening uh uh
platform and i look forward to following
your campaign
thank you david i really appreciate it
so that's that's pretty pretty full-on
bonkers stuff guys um
we'll have that
probably an abbreviated
uh version of that
next week on the podcast and um
yeah well i mean i know i know it's
it's pretty eye opening yeah exactly
i want to say thank you to mark halks
mark just gifted a membership on my
website and is number 21
that membership goes to misty row misty
row is the next person up
um yeah the no the interview was was
pretty yikes yeah if you would like a
free membership go to davidpakman.com
free membership now if you are in a
position where you could gift a
membership i would love for you to do
that you go to joinpakman.com you pick
any membership i suggest yearly
and as you go through the sign up
process
the box is this a gift you just check it
okay you check the box and then i can
give the membership to somebody right
now we have 690 people waiting the next
person up is devon bunch devon bunch
would be the recipient
of the next gifted membership
we are back i'm going to take a five and
we will continue
[Music]
so
all right
all right mr conley can you hear me okay
i can't yes
can you just count to count to five for
me please
one two three four five perfect thank
you all right
next question
all right mr connolly um we were talking
about hicksville there and you made a
comment that um
you had suggested to mr depp and miss
heard that they
they keep it private or something along
those lines
uh
jess mike my question is just what
prompted you to make that
suggestion
well it was getting kind of uh animated
you know it was
animated and you know no one wants to
see the
earth abducted laundry in public
uh were they both animated
uh more so
amber
johnny yes but more so amber
do you remember anything in particular
that ms heard was saying at the time
i don't recall no
as i say it wasn't really coherent it
was more of the animation that you know
the
the head movements and the stern looks
and stuff that made prompting me to do
what i have to do you know
okay
uh shifting gears a little bit um
you listed out various places that you
traveled with with mr deb and miss heard
and i think you listed japan germany
hicksville and australia do i have that
right
correct yes
when were you in australia
i'll be
15 2015
pirates five
and uh
what were you doing in australia
uh
my job uh
i
in that occasion i flew out first i used
to fly at first to do the advance
uh the advance includes
the checking of accommodation
not so much accommodation because uh
nathan holmes
uh ben king
and the chef called russell they had
already been been at the home excuse me
been at the home
and got that sorted out
my main concern was locations
transport uh
local security uh
drivers you know
making sure all that's in line before
johnny gets there
jerry judge would have traveled with
johnny industrial
on arrival uh i would have picked him up
at the airport as they do take them to
the the house
where our accommodation was staying in
and uh i would i would have peeled off
the left at that
went back to my apartment
johnny would have been
maybe it could be up to a week for
[Music]
you know a makeup
costume before any shooting stuff
and which time it gives me a time to run
around some locations
the studio check out the studio the
locations
well as be around for if johnny wants to
go for dinner at night anywhere i would
check out these places as well
mr connolly i'm sorry i i just had a
little trouble hearing you there could i
might be the might be the connection but
could you speak maybe just a little bit
slower i'm sorry
okay
um as i say
my job when in australia is just to
secure all the advance
so i would check out make sure the local
drivers are there all the cars are in
order the accommodations in order
the locations
for shooting are all safe
liaison with production
what's expected of them
i would pick them up at the airport when
he arrives take him to the accommodation
peel off go and check out a few
restaurants in case he wants to go
and if nothing's happening uh standing
for that evening
does anything stand out to you about
your time in australia in 2015
yeah johnny lost a finger
um
yeah uh
yeah one afternoon i was uh instructed
to go to johnny's accommodation
objection and can we just
okay all right
hold on it's minute mr economy so now
they're going to get to a critical issue
which is the incident in which uh johnny
depp got
a piece of his finger cut off and this
is pretty it's been pretty central so
far to the entire case so i imagine
they're going to want to figure out what
can and can't be said thanks to 222 damo
for gifting a twitch subscription you're
number 22 today also want to say thanks
to quentin tickler
for gifting two more subscriptions on my
website those go to
tim mazziel
and jason donnelly really appreciate
that i know people have been emailing
saying david sir you you said my name i
get a free membership and i haven't
gotten it
we it's gonna take a few days to catch
up with the backlog
all right mr mr connolly
please continue but but as you as you go
please avoid
discussing the substance of any
communications that you had with mr depp
uh or or his security and just focus on
what you observed
okay
i arrive
at johnny's accommodation
was my driver andrew
i noticed that there's an suv
one of the security the the rst resident
security team one of their vehicles is
sitting outside the door no driver
so
i just assumed
just well something up was a security
car there but no driver as i approached
the door i hear a muffle like a muffled
shouting and screaming and
you know
quite muffled though because the
entrance to this house there's a massive
oak door i mean it's huge
and it's got to be about 25 mil thick
so i'll open it
and it's chaos it's uh
screaming and shouting but
oh oh i can see when my eye is johnny
he's wearing a
jacket
a hat
and a bag with these notebooks
i always know that bag because it's a
grey canvas bag
and he's
sort of you know nuts in one hand
so i'm saying well hey what's going on
button is screaming and shouting
with madness
amber's amber's irate i mean tenacious
it's crazy stuff
johnny's uh you know shouting back
so i've said johnny let's go let's go
you know
that's my job to remove them from a
situation let's go
i do a couple of steps for some
johnny give me five minutes now five
minutes well he's a boss you know
there's no gay there's no bill it's
flying so
okay give him two minutes how about i
say let's go let's go eventually i get
him out i managed to get him outside the
door
we go downstairs
but amber appears from somewhere no i
don't know if i was upstairs or in the
room to the left or
wherever
but she appears and she's screaming
you know screaming
but eating them she's basically berating
him
like yes [ __ ] off she's saying johnny
dead that's what you do [ __ ] off that's
what you do all the time that's all you
ever do is [ __ ] off you [ __ ] off with
your guys you're [ __ ] covered that's
what you [ __ ] do
you [ __ ] kill up yeah [ __ ] off with
your guys your big man all that all that
[ __ ] that goes with it
get some downstairs
uh palestine members on the threshold of
the the the
the
accommodation
she's uh screaming you know [ __ ] off
your [ __ ] cover that you kind of
works you know
and uh i get them in the car and i want
to sit in the same i usually sit in the
front seat shotgun but i want to sit in
the same seat at the back so i can have
a look at what's going on here and have
a chat and have a talk
but when i get around the car
the driver has not locked the door
so he's out the door again and he's
making his way back up the stairs i get
back around again
by the time i get to the top there's two
two concrete stairs to the front door
he's just crossing the threshold
and and the screaming starting
again excuse me amber is screaming
again johnny let's go let's go
and this time it's a wee bit more force
and i managed to actually basically pull
him out of the place
get him into the car doors are locked
his time
into the car when we take off
i got them back to my apartment using
[Music]
you know a secret way through the
underground car park and
serviceless
i get them up to my apartment
uh get him into my apartment
while she start washing his hand
basically creating his hand washing it
first aid
it's a mess his hand his finger's just a
mess it's like one of them cartoon
exploding cigars i was always thinking
in my mind that one of them
one of them see how's it blow up you
know the cartoons boom
and uh it's soft laughing around and i
could see bone there's bone there's
smashed a bit and he's you know he's
wincing as i'm trying to wash his hand
uh anyway i set him down and i phoned
debbie and debbie the nurse who who's
living in the same apartment off of me
so that's my first thing phone debbie
fun debbie about 20 minutes later
if that i'd wrote the call
uh maybe 25 maybe half an hour
but she turns up with the dr kipper
so um
at first i was thinking the accent was
an impediment to understanding i'm
actually realizing it's a big part of
why this is so compelling there's
perhaps a hospital with us there's no
there's no other way we have to go to
the hospital this has to be seriously
looked at
we get to the hospital and that's when
he's ah
well he that's when his treatment
started you know
okay
um
when you
when you were in the presence of of mr
depp and miss heard in the house in
australia
how far away were you from miss herd
um
when i first entered the house miss head
wasn't uh visible to me
only johnny it's only when we started to
leave
his head appeared
and she's probably
well you're talking
two feet three feet
did you observe any injuries on this
hurt
no injuries no no injuries i'll allow it
what's the objection i'm sorry what was
your answer
no injuries
none other than the injury to his finger
did you observe any injuries on mr on mr
death
no
no
no
well
i say no
you know there was there was a mark in
his face and i i i didn't know what that
was so i never really put it down too
much
but uh in the hospital i took a
photograph
and when i look when i look at that
photograph
i can see two injuries
when we're sitting in the car i'm
spelling hold on mr khan
objection to the extent he's gonna be
talking about what the mark is on his
since he didn't see what happened and
he's not a doctor we can't describe what
we could see what he saw uh uh that's
fine you're on a weekend week
one okay yeah all right next question
um
i think you've generally described for
us uh
the kinds of things ms heard was saying
how would you describe her overall
demeanor when when she and mr depp were
in the in in each other's presence in
the house in australia
um
good days and bad days
i'm sorry i mean on that particular day
on that particular day i had never seen
them now it's not particularly the only
the time i seen
uh
miss herb and johnny in that house is
when i arrived there to extract them
extraction and how did miss heard seem
to you when you saw her uh on that day
when you arrived to extract him
crazy
crazy
crazy
fierce you know fierce
okay
what was the what was the last thing
miss heard said as you were taking mr
death out of the house to to go to your
apartment and then the hospital
yeah
the last one what i recall hearing is as
i'm getting johnny out is yeah just [ __ ]
off you guys you're [ __ ] covered like
you always do
all right i have no further questions
all right cross-examination
this should be interesting
let's see which of the lawyers are doing
it
um
mr connolly uh this guy you still work
for mr depp
i do yeah okay and you've worked for him
now for about 18 years
no
well two years ago you you said you
worked for him for 16 years so two more
years would be 18. oh i i worked with
him i didn't work for him i worked for a
guy called jerry judge and music and
arts johnny depp never paid me
johnny depp started paying me two years
ago okay so now you're being so you you
were working
jerry judge was your jerry judge was
your boss until he passed away is that
right
okay and now and now you get paid
directly by mr depp correct
right
you paid a salary by mr depp
no
okay
and you mr depths also provided you
gifts correct
gifts gifts
money gift yes
yes guess johnny's giving me gifts i've
given johnny girl
and you've had she's given you gifts
over eighty five hundred dollars correct
eighty five hundred dollars yeah
it gave me a lot more than that okay
you're loyal to mr depp right oh god
i'm yes of course i'm loyal to myself
i'll be loyal to you if i was working
for you okay
um
now going to australia
you said you went to australia in 2015
with mr depp correct
or you went before mr depp but you you
were there to work for mr deaf correct
all right and and jerry judge was also
there
nope when i arrived no but he eventually
was jerry judge was eventually in
australia correct
right and nathan holmes was also in
australia as well right
right
and mr depp came to australia in
february of 2015. correct
correct and when
when
mr dep first came to australia amber was
not with mr deck right
i don't recall i don't recall amber
arrived with johnny or
amber arrived
you don't know one way or the other
no
and mr deputy stayed in a house in
australia corrupt
right and you and the security team were
about 40 minutes away from the house mr
depp was running correct
25 30.
20
30 40 yeah you could yeah you're correct
if it's a traffic day you have 40
minutes or more
and alcohol was in the house in
australia correct
correct
and mr depp consumed alcohol before
amber arrived in australia isn't that
right
yeah he would have done yes okay and
you know if mr depp consumed illegal
drugs before amber arrived in australia
going to object to speculation
i wouldn't know
good
and
do you know if mr depp spent any time
with marilyn manson in australia before
amber arrived uh oh
don't recall i don't recall i don't
recall marlon manson being there
so you don't so as mr def security you
don't know if if mr depp was with
marilyn manson and i i left
i left australia to smuggle two dogs
back out or steal your back too no no no
i'm talking about it i'm talking about
in the beginning of march
2015
you were that you were you were
you don't know one way or the other
no
were you were you seeing mr depp every
day
in early morning
no not at the beginning i don't know
duties okay
so you don't know what mr depp was doing
at that time correct
no i wasn't with him okay and you don't
know when amber arrived into uh in
australia correct
no okay but you do know that amber
stayed with mr depp right
yes okay and you talked about a resident
security team that was at the um
australia house is that right
that's correct
and were there about four
is it
was there anyone it from the resident
security team in the house when you
arrived on uh march 8th 2015.
no okay and the resident security team
is it your understanding that they were
there that they were kind of guarding
the house
they would have been in the grounds but
the substantial grounds
real substantial ground
they would have hit the ground somewhere
but they didn't but they didn't go into
the house on on march 8th correct
i don't know i never seen them in the
house okay
and so when you arrived at the house and
and went and went in was it just
mr depp and amber heard
just mr that number okay and before
maybe someone else here i never visibly
seen anyone else i wasn't there long
enough to chat to anybody and when you
arrived at the house you could you could
hear a ruckus correct
yes well yes i could hear no yeah yeah i
could hear definitely hear something
through the the the door yeah
but you said the door was so thick you
couldn't hear the actual words that were
being said is that right
no just a
a shouting
and then you saw then you went in the
house and saw mr depp in the foyer
correct
yes correct and mr depp was trying to
urinate in the four year wasn't he
no
mr jeff had his penis out of his
objection sydney
i think relevance
he's going to allow the penis inquiry
and you were trying to get mr deb out of
the house correct
correct i'll try to get mr deb out of
the house yes and mr depp was refusing
to leave the house was he not
not so much refused he just wanted two
minutes to save peace you took mr depp's
arm to try to move him out but he broke
away isn't that right
yes okay i mean so he was strong enough
to break away from your grip correct
no
you had his arm and he broke away though
correct
no
isn't that what you just said
no i let him go you let go
yes but it wasn't easy it wasn't me
so mr depp's your boss you'll do what mr
dev wants correct
no
it's not easy to get mr deb out of the
house
correct not easy
yeah now can we put can we play um
exhibit 380 a which is already in
evidence
planos are defendants i'm sorry uh it's
defendant's exhibit 380a this is wild
huh
what what is this uh sorry what is this
and this is a recording from australia
and it's just of mr depp
i don't think that's an evidence here
hold on it's not an evidence plaintiff's
exhibit 380a i don't believe there are
any recordings from australia and
evidence here i don't think that i think
there's there definitely is it's it's of
just of mr dab we can three i don't have
three not even in evidence it's 380a
this is historic
i have jamie says it was id but never
admitted
it was never admitted it was
your honor the recordings from australia
have other voices on them
for the it's only the clip of mr david
okay well i have it's it's actually
plaintiff's 380 a
minute 33 to 34.
what's the foundation for using it with
this witness he was at he was at the
house
it's an evidence that's fine
oh boy so you're playing that clip
correct correct that is on plaintiffs
and who wow are and how do you [ __ ] me
over
and make me feel sick
of myself
[Music]
did you did you hear that mr connolly
i did yes and that was the sort of
condition mr depp was in when you saw
him at the house correct
yes yes mr depp was upset and angry when
you saw him at the house correct
absolutely yes okay
now
did you take did you take mr depp to the
hospital
along with all those yes
is it your testimony that mr depp was
coherent at the hospital
yes
um can you let's show um defendants
exhibit 370 and i'd just like you to
look at something for a moment
i'm not i'm not putting it i'm not
publishing i just want to
show them a document defendants exhibit
370.
your honor i'm going to object on
foundation grounds to witnesses not even
copied on this document i'm i'm going to
ask him a question and ask him if it if
it refreshes his recollection that's all
i was going to ask him about i can i can
use any document to refresh maybe you
want to approach for psychology
uh getting really i mean this is this
this episode this finger cut off episode
is uh a critical part of of at least the
case so far and we'll see if and how
that changes once um
one once amber heard's
case starts to be made
for lack of a better term um
it it it is all surreal it's uh i mean i
know some of you don't like it when i
say this but this entire thing is
kafka-esque
in any number of ways any number of ways
i want to say thanks to norbert hinckley
for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com i really appreciate that
and everybody everybody's support
of the stream also 222 damo keeps
gifting subscriptions on twitch and i
appreciate that too how much longer is
this expected to go today
likely about 15 minutes they've been
ending at 5 eastern and weeks left in
the trial weeks left
5 30 some are saying okay maybe 5 30.
you can take it
switch stock now
you can take it down
was um mr depp's finger was filled with
dirt grime and paint when you saw it
yes
and now you say you saw no bruises or
cuts on on amber on march 8 2015 correct
isn't it true that your main concern was
mr depp and getting him out of the house
correct
you were so you weren't you weren't
concentrating on amber correct
i was close enough if there was any
marks on amber's face i would have
picked that up in two minutes as you're
trying to change this
as you're trying to pull as you're
trying to pull as you're trying to pull
mr deb out of the house you're you're
scanning amber for bruises and cuts
no scanning but i'm looking at her
as you're moving as you're moving mr def
out of the house correct yes yes how do
i know where she's going to lift right
i'm watching her when i'm when i move a
client from a bar situation a house
situation i watch what's happening
around me but you're not i know where
the client is the client's with me
right the client was with you and you're
not scanning you didn't scan miss
heard's body for i scan everything you
scanned everything on your body
no everything in her body she's wearing
long sleeves from what i recall okay
um
and
at the hospital the doctor was told that
mr depp cut his finger with a knife
correct
correct yeah okay
and you understand that the damage at
the house
mr depp
at mr departed house amounted to about a
hundred thousand dollars correct
objection calls for speculation
i'll allow it that's right next question
in hicksville other than when you first
arrived you didn't go to the trailer
that mr depp and amber were saying is
that right
only when i delivered them to it right
and then after you delivered them
together
when i delivered them to it when we
first got there right we went inside and
had to look around yeah but after that
you never went inside the trailer after
that correct
correct so you have no idea what went on
in the trailer between mr depp and amber
isn't that right
i was told
but you have no idea you don't have any
personal knowledge as to why i never
seen it right well i never seen it and
you know you have no idea how much
damage was done to the trailer correct
personal knowledge you have an idea
you have no idea what happened to amber
in the trailer isn't that right that's
correct
and you don't and and you talked about
that there was tension between amber and
mr deputy you don't know what started
the fight correct
right
did you see mr depp grab another woman's
arm before they moved off to the truck
before
the fight started
no okay were you with mister were you
with the company when you were the were
you with the group
no okay
obviously i was maybe
20 feet away observing that's my job not
to get involved i don't sit with my
clients in a personal situation i've
just observed
now
you testified
that at times you saw
marks and
bruises on mr depp a fat lip i think you
said
um
you don't have dates for those times
that you saw that right
i don't recall no you're talking that's
a long time ago you know it's right and
you testified and you testified in the
uk in this you testified in the uk
correct
correct and you gave a witness statement
too in the uk correct
all right and and you never testified to
seeing any marks bruises or injuries on
mr depp isn't that right in the uk
i wasn't asked to the uk but you never
testified that you never testified to
that right
i wasn't asked okay
now
use in the private you talked about a
private plane that you saw a plastic
lighter bounce off of mr depp's chest
correct
right and you said you saw mr mr depp
smirking and said and then he said was
that it is that right
no
okay you didn't you don't know what
started the fight there correct
correct okay
and you talked about at the easter at
the eb at the uh lofts i think you
called it in los angeles
you saw a coke can
get thrown
somewhere in the vicinity of mr depp
correct it was pepsi
i've seen a can
right not caught can i come i couldn't
tell you what kind it was okay
and you don't know
what happened before you saw the coke
can get thrown correct
correct
okay and
you talked you talked about this picture
of um
that you took in in southeast asia
correct
right okay
and you never mentioned in the uk matter
or in your witness statement
mr depp having scratches and bruises on
the train correct
i was never prompted i was never asked
you gave a witness statement that gave
the
the what you saw and the relationship
between amber and mr depp and you never
talked about
bruises or cuts on mr on mr depp in
southeast asia correct
no i wasn't asked that okay
um now
you said oh only johnny could make
requests for a private dining car isn't
that right
i said that
only johnny needed a private dining car
mr didn't need a private dining car
correct that would be correct oh yeah
that would definitely be correct yeah
only only johnny depp would need a
private dining car but johnny doesn't
want a private dining car
okay
you were not present and misheard and
misheard in mr dep's cabin on the train
right no and if a fight occurred
and if a fight occurred in the cabin
you'd have no way of knowing about it
right
i wouldn't know and you don't know if mr
depp was
strangling this herd do you
no i wouldn't know you don't know if mr
depp had his shirt wrapped around
amber's neck do you
objection speculation communal lift
no i didn't know you only know i would
the only reason i would know anything in
that cabinet okay you wouldn't know you
answered sir sir so you answered that
all right uh we can move on okay sir
man
um if we could put up please um
plaintiff's exhibit
120
you can't say one way or the other
whether he was chopping her up with an
axe
in in evidence i have 120 a 120 b and
120 c so i think this would be 120 d if
it 120 d
yeah okay
this is this is a little absurd but
mr connolly i'm asking you questions
about the
fourth um
one down do you see that
um the document is hearsay i don't know
what the exception would be okay i'll
hold if you want to come forward
uh another document um attempted to be
disqualified as hearsay by johnny depp's
lawyers here yeah this this is it's
getting quite intense it really is
um
it
all of it is is is
bizarre to some degree
who's next up on free memberships next
is liam hildenbrand is the next person
waiting yeah if you want a free
membership just go to
davidpakman.comfreemembership.com
uh 687
people waiting 687
many anxious people waiting
live stream tomorrow starts at 8 p east
5p west it will be a trump rally in the
state of nebraska
we will have
all sorts of different coverage of what
will be going on on the ground i expect
it to all be pretty weaponized and
it will probably all make us sad about
the state of affairs in the united
states i would assume that yeah i would
i would expect that
it will be live on twitch it will be
live on facebook it will be live on
youtube as well
let's see if i can squeeze in one
voicemail this will
they might be almost done but let's just
let's very briefly hear from whitney
so
do you believe that europe really found
flaws and stuff in the paperwork um i do
i actually saw the paperwork and it was
it was riddled with flaws
and grammatical errors i would say one
more from nope it looks like they're
done oh well let's see
but i really feel like um
like i have a lot of support with the
military good all right back to the
trial
mr connolly um
you agree that miss hurt's been nothing
but respectful and professional to you
correct
absolutely right
okay
thank you i have nothing further all
right redirect
uh mr mr connolly very briefly uh when
you were in miss heard's presence in the
house in australia uh on the day that mr
depp uh lost his fingertip
how far away were you from his herd
on the exit
on the the egress
about
three feet four feet at north
can you estimate for us about how long
you were in this herd's presence
oh you know what best way to do this is
think about it and count it out okay
thorough
thorough witness
15 seconds 20 seconds
how was the light
well it's australia the door is uh
massive
it's a wall of glass behind them it's
australia absolutely fine you couldn't
get better
very bright in australia
all right i have nothing for that all
right is this
subject to recall
i i think i think so yes your honor all
right mr connolly since you're subject
to recall did not discuss your testimony
with anybody and don't watch anything
about this case okay but you're free to
log off today
all right you're free to log off today
though thank you have a good day
there's mr connolly all right your next
witness
mr jenkins
yeah
well quite an extensive legal team here
mr jenkins can you hear me sir
good afternoon yes i can your honor all
right perfect thank you sir all right
if you raise your right hand for me
do you swear firm to tell the truth
under penalty of law
i do all right thank you sir
good morning mr jenkins can you hear me
okay
yes i can and could you please state
your full name for the record
startling jenkins iii
and mr jenkins where do you live
los angeles california
and what is your occupation
executive chauffeur security
and how long have you worked as an
executive chauffeur and in security
executive chauffeur for 30 years
security security
for eight years
and and what occupations did you hold
prior to working as an executive
chauffeur and and in security
the route sales executive
and united states marines
mr jenkins do you know the point if in
this case johnny depp
yes i do and when did you first meet mr
deb
1993
how did you first meet mr dab
he is delivery service to transport him
to and from
so in in the 30 or so years that you've
known mr depp what services have you
performed for him uh over the course of
that period
child care animal care
personal assistant duties security and
transportation
and and could you uh estimate
approximately how many hours per week
would you provide those services to mr
depp
40 to 60 hours
and can you describe generally your
interactions with mr depp in the time
that you've worked for him
pleasant always upbeat
do you know the defendant in this case
amber heard
yes
and when did you first meet miss heard
after the filming of the rum diary
project
can you describe generally your
interactions with miss hurt
pleasant claw joe very respectful
and so in your time working with mr depp
did you uh ever observe mr depps and
miss herd's interactions with one
another
yes
and can you describe those interactions
generally please
very cordial very
aware that people are around them very
very friendly do you ever see them argue
yes
can you describe what you observed about
those arguments
it would be initiated by her
she would try to engage with him he
would tell me to turn the music on
so um where did these arguments take
place
in the car
oh man
do you recall how many times you
witnessed them argue
twice
mr jenkins turning your attention to
april 21st 2016.
uh can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
could you repeat the question sir
sure so turning your attention to april
21st 2016
can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
it was the birthday party being held at
the penthouse
and when you say the penthouse what are
you referring to
it's the eastern columbia building
and what were you doing that evening
that evening i was assigned security on
the detail
were you inside the residence uh while
the birthday party was taking place
i was in the cp the command post that's
stationed on the same floor right
outside of the elevator
and did you interact with miss heart at
all that evening
yes i did
with regards to getting her clients
keys
parking
making sure no one else was on the floor
that wasn't invited to the party
were there any issues at the birthday
party uh at the time
uh that you were present at the
penthouses
no issues except for the boss did not
show up and do you recall what time you
left that day
11 15 p.m that evening
and mr jenkins what happened the next
day april 22nd 2016.
i arrived early 10 45
i went upstairs to the penthouse i was
informed by amber that she got in the
fight with johnny last night she threw
his personal property over the balcony
into the streets ninth and broadway
and when you say personal property what
are you referring to
his phone wallet
credit cards passports everything that's
in his wallet
did uh miss hurt say anything else to
you about this altercation
nothing except she
they were fighting
so what what did you do after miss heard
informed you that she had thrown mr
depp's personal property off the balcony
formulated a plan with norm from the
office to use the find my phone app
hit the streets and
try to get lucky
did you end up finding mr depp's phone
yes i did in skid row
probably six miles from the house
and who had the who had the phone
a
homeless gentleman unhoused gentleman
i approached him about the phone
he was honest he returned it i gave him
reward for it and what was the reward
four hundred and twenty dollars
four
oh it's perfect fiji oh my god 420 this
that is that is amazing mr depp's phone
what did you do
420. i returned to the penthouse
showed the phone to amber that i
retrieved it i left it in the sheet in
the cp for the evening security to
return it to mr deb wow so after
figuring out uh things with the phone
what what happened next
what happened next is i walked amber to
the car we got everybody in the car
she's on her way to coachella i went
back to the penthouse to retrieve the
dogs and the luggage
were you also going to coachella with
miss heard
yes i was i was the transportation for
amber and her friends while she was at
coachella
so how did you get to coachella
enjoy the suv
did you or did you not enjoy the set by
two-door cinema club
and headed out
to the event
and the the morning of april 22nd did
you see uh any injuries on misheard
no marks
no injuries
um and so uh driving out to coachella
did anyone drive with you
i was in the car alone except for the
ends
and how did miss heard get to coachella
she drove a mustang
was anyone else in her car
she was with i believe her sister and
one other friend her assistant savannah
and do you know how many days uh miss
heard and her friends were planning to
stay at coachella
so the following monday i believe it's
the 25th of april
we departed
and do you recall where miss herd was
staying at coachella
was staying at the parker
boutique hotels there in palm springs
outside of coachella were you also
staying at the parker hotel
i also stayed there
and so did you attend coachella for work
or for pleasure
for work
and what was your job that weekend
provide security and transportation
animal care
amber is rolling assisted take care of
her whatever she needed while she was
there at the parker or in the out
traveling
do you recall what time approximately
you arrived at the parker hotel on april
22nd
around
5 30 maybe quarter to six and and what
did miss hurt and her friends do that
evening april 22nd
that evening
we arrived
we were assigned the rooms we went with
the
with the
staff of the parker hotel around to the
suites where we were staying they let us
in
we let all the luggage in
and uh suites at that hotel are about
1700 a night
planned for that evening to depart by
seven
7 15 is to get to the festival there
and and how did miss hurt and her
friends get from the hotel to the
festival that evening
i drove them directly to there
and did you have any discussions with
miss heard on the way to coachella that
evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving
and when you refer to the surprise in
the boss's bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong it
went wrong
oh god
mr jenkins what observations did you
make about miss heard at coachella in
april 2016
she had no worry she was there to whoop
it up it's her birthday she's with her
friends
and how often were you with her that
weekend
was with her
like in what way did it go wrong you
know from the time that we interacted
with the defecation oh my god the night
before at the party all the way until
monday we returned
with the pets and the luggage
and did you uh observe anything about
miss hurt's health that weekend
she got sick do you know what got sick
at the venue back at night do you know
what cosmis heard to be sick
she was eating the magic mushrooms and
drinking red wine on an empty stomach
and uh how do you know that she drank
red wine and took magic mushrooms
i saw the room service and i went to
their room to collect them to take them
out that evening so is that something
excuse me is that something you
witnessed
i witnessed it
and what did you do
in response to miss heard being sick at
coachella
i collected her
got her in the vehicle
she didn't want anybody else to know
that she was sick take her back to the
parker alone i took her to the 7-eleven
where i retrieved hydrating fluids advil
and
better have those got her back to the
parker got her into the suite and then
went back to pick up everyone else wow
and mr jenkins when you said uh miss
heard got sick do you recall what her
symptoms were
yeah she was throwing up
mr jenkins did you see any injuries of
any kind i misheard april 22nd 2016.
no injuries i'll sustain you so yes
what about the rest of that weekend mr
jenkins any injuries that you saw
no injuries
i like this um
have you ever witnessed any physical
abuse between mr depp and miss heard
no
thank you mr jenkins nothing further all
right cross examination
seems like a good guy i don't know
doesn't have a lot of uh
interest in being a player here
good afternoon
so just just to be clear on the
chronology um you met mr depp in 1993 is
that right
correct and you've worked for him ever
since
off and on yes okay and your your salary
is paid by mr depp correct
salary
no
you receive pay for the work that you do
for mr jeff correct of course yes of
course and what mr depp's security is
your highest priority in your job
correct
yes he does you're loyal to mister
and his family you're loyal to mr depp
right
yes
now i want to turn to the the
the night of april 21st 2016.
you just just to recap you said you were
working a security shift at amber's
birthday
at the eastern columbia building that
evening correct
correct and you said that your shift
ended around 11 15
correct
correct
and
you you said the boss still hadn't shown
up by the time that you left the eastern
columbia building right
correct
so you have no idea
where mr depp was or what he was doing
from 9 30 p.m that evening until
at least 11 15 when you left the eastern
columbia building right
no i do know what he was doing he was
attending to his mother
you weren't with him
i had information okay
all right
that's information that you
that you received but you you have no
personal knowledge of that i have no
reason to doubt it
i have no reasons we i have no reason to
doubt it it came from sean there you go
okay
oh it's oh okay so mr mr bet told you
that
the boss is out there right admit mr
bett told you that he was tending to his
mother that night
he didn't say mother he said the boss
was out there
i'm aware of what the situation was the
time frame
he's with his mother okay all right
interesting okay
um is that interesting
and did you have any understanding that
he had a meeting with his new business
manager earlier that evening where he
was told that he was running out of
money and that his taxes hadn't been
paid in years did you have any
understanding of that objection for
anyone else objection foundation
cultural speculation i'll sustain the
objection next question
and you didn't see mr depp that night
right
no i didn't know
interesting came back the next morning
to escort amber to coachella
right yes and you say that amber told
you that she had thrown
mr depp's phone off the roof
correct and did you come to understand
that um mr depp had thrown her phone off
the roof that evening prior to when
amber threw mr depp's phone off the roof
she informed me of that
okay she informed you of that so when
you went outside
to look for
mr depp's phone you you weren't looking
for miss heard's phone were you
she had her phone she had her phone she
was trying to
re-download and back it up okay so she
you were only looking for mr depp's
phone because she had her went
downstairs so this to the to uh to try
to yeah hers was in her hand with an
unhoused person you said correct
correct okay and you did you did i hear
you right that you said it was six miles
away where you found the phone
correct
it actually wasn't six miles away it was
it was actually right below the building
the ecb building correct okay let's not
can you pull up um
does he have a way to see documents that
just just him your honor yes
um could you please pull up uh
the witness statement mr jenkins mr
jenkins do you do you remember giving
testimony on mr depp's behalf in the uk
trial
yes i did
and
um you gave you gave a witness statement
first in in writing correct do you
remember that
yes and then you were examined um by the
attorneys in the trial correct
correct okay
can you see on your screen the statement
uh that's
do you see a witness statement
yes i see it it says witness statement
of starling jenkins right
right and this is the statement that you
wrote and signed as part of the uh the
uk trial on behalf of mr depp correct
correct this should be interesting if
you can scroll please to page 3 of the
document
and
mr jenkins i'm going to read you
what you wrote in paragraph 13.
okay
and
everybody's riveted
um on paragraph 13 you wrote
in your witness statement in the uk
trial
the
find my iphone application indicated
that johnny's phone was somewhere on the
streets below the balcony of the
residence
did i read that right
if that's what it says that's what it
says i'm telling you the phone was in
skid row okay so photo of the gentleman
that found it i have the location where
the phone was found isn't skid row just
a few blocks away from the eastern
columbia building
no it's uh it's on sixth and
main i guess depending on what error you
are okay so so one of these two sworn
statements either what you just said in
court just now that it was found six
miles away or this one of these is false
correct
uh it's
it's just inadequate as far as the
location the location is not below
the the penthouse it's not on broadway
it's found on broadway by the unhoused
man and then he lives off of skid row
okay
now let's move on to coachella please
you is it possible at some point the
phone was in the first location but it
ultimately was retrieved where the skid
row guy was i mean i don't know say that
amber and her friends were having a good
time that weekend
yes
and there were thousands of other people
at that music festival too correct
correct okay to your to
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney was
pregnant and sober that weekend
wasn't my information was my knowledge
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney threw up in a parking lot that
weekend
no okay to your knowledge and
understanding mr jenkins um there's
nothing wrong with wanting to spend time
with your friends at a music festival
after being abused by your husband right
whoa
how is there no objection
it's not an abnormal thing to want to be
around your friends correct
she was partying up with her friends she
was partying it up and you said you
didn't hear anything about she didn't
say anything to you about domestic
violence having taken place correct
nothing in the car pertaining to that
would it surprise you that she might not
want to talk to someone who had worked
for her husband for around 23 years at
that point about domestic violence would
that surprise you speculation objection
speculation your honor sustain the
objection next question
mr texted you on may 12
2016 asking you to call her correct
correct
and you did not bother to respond to
that text correct
correct
and that was the last communication that
you had with her
correct correct
now you weren't um just to be clear you
weren't at amber's house on orange
avenue in march 2013 when johnny was
there correct
i might have driven him to the location
i'm familiar with the address but you
didn't enter the house at any point in
march 2013 correct
depending there is a good point leading
questions are allowed in virginia during
cross-examination for hostile or
adversarial witnesses
harry have been waiting in the car
and you weren't at the hicksville
trailer palace in late may or early june
2013 right
no
you weren't on a plane flight from
boston to los angeles in may 2014
correct with with johnny and amber
you weren't in the you weren't with mr
death and amber in the bahamas in august
2014 correct
correct
you weren't with mr depp and amber in
tokyo in january 2015 correct
uh no i was not there correct you
weren't with mr depp and amber in
australia in march 2015 correct
correct
you weren't at thanksgiving with them in
penthouse i mean this is kind of dumb i
understand why it's being done but he's
only there to talk about what he
observed when he was involved of course
he does it i mean it's like no i wasn't
in australia i don't know what happened
in australia maybe there was abuse maybe
there wasn't abuse
sure sure you don't have any specific
recollection of that one way or the
other though correct
i would probably say i was on duty that
day okay it's the holiday okay um you
weren't celebrating thanksgiving in
penthouse five with them that evening
correct
i was in the cp okay and that's that's a
separate room correct
separate room on the same level correct
and you weren't in the bahamas in late
december 2015 correct
with them correct you weren't in the ecb
with just the two of them the night of
december 15th 25th
no one of the security guards
was present for all of the alleged or or
or non-abuse elements right i mean there
was a number of different employees here
house of the eastern columbia building
on the night of may 21st 2016 with mr
depp and miss heard correct
correct
and and and you'd agree that you have no
personal knowledge of what went on
between mr depp and miss heard behind
closed doors correct
correct
nothing further thank you all right
redirect
just very quick on your honor do we have
mr jenkins witness statement
or perhaps
the food is here
and if we could go to the third page
please
mr jenkins directing your attention to
paragraph 13 which mr rottenborn had you
look at just a second ago
he read the first sentence of that
witness statement um
to find my phone find my iphone
application indicating that giant's
phone was somewhere on the streets
before the balkan residence walked out
could you could you please read for the
jury the the second part of the
that paragraph
i walked out onto the street did not see
the phone i then
asked several homeless people if they
had the phone one homeless man admitted
to me that he had the phone returned the
phone to me in exchange for the
following
425 in cash three chicken tacos two bags
of chips four apples two apples four
bottles of water
and so do you do you recall where you
found the iphone that day
yes i did action asked and answered all
right i'll sustain the objection next
question
mr jenkins moving to uh coachella
mr rottenborn at you about um rottenborn
whitney heard do you know who that is
yes i do do you know the difference
between whitney heard and amber heard
yes i do and who was sick that is the
boss why
one is the boss's sister-in-law who was
sick that day at coachella
amber was sick
thank you nothing further all right is
this witness subject to recall
no your honor all right mr jenkins
you're um
you're free from testimony and therefore
you're free to to do whatever you need
to do or you can watch the proceedings
it's up to you but uh you're you're done
for today though thank you sir
thank you ronnie thank you for the court
all right have a good day very polite
gentleman
all right
all right i think it's close enough to 5
30 that i think we've had enough
of a week ladies and gentlemen at this
time we're going to go ahead and
be done with the testimony for this week
although since i won't see until monday
i want to give you
the long jury instruction that i give
you every every thursday evening just so
we all remember our responsibilities
okay
so at this time remember that you are
not to read anything about this case
you are not to watch anything about this
case you are not to listen to anything
about this case this applies to
television newspapers magazines the
internet and any online sites
uh further you are not to read watch or
listen to do we do we believe that the
jurors are not looking up anything about
this trial i mean it's it's quite
literally everywhere it's just i i
i'd be curious to hear from a trial
attorney's do you just assume jurors are
looking at stuff and you hope it's not
that much or what what's the you know
what's the approach is family co-workers
acquaintances and strangers i also
instruct you that you cannot do any
research or make inquiries about this
case whether online or by any other
means
for example please also do not watch
better call saul or any other legal
shows persons involved in this case
normally you consult dictionaries or
other reference materials what you learn
about this case is limited to what you
learn in the four walls of this
courtroom when proceedings are underway
you also may not communicate about this
case or the person's involved in this
case with your fellow jurors okay hope
you have a good weekend it's supposed to
be great weather on saturday go outside
get some fresh air okay and just enjoy
your weekend and we'll see you back
monday at 10 okay thank you so much
what a day
oh there's no friday stuff on the uh on
this trial interesting
all right
and as always mr mr depp and ms heard
please do not do any posting on social
media and do not talk to the press i
appreciate it and have a good weekend
for the attorneys tomorrow
um what time how many did we do our
homework this week yes
we did
work in progress okay so are we still
doing
19 tomorrow
20s you added one for me that's lovely
okay great so we'll do 20 tomorrow so i
would suggest 8 o'clock can everybody be
here at eight sound good
okay we'll be here at 8am and we'll just
do them until we're done so bring a lot
of meals okay
all right we'll see you tomorrow then
thank you have a good evening all right
everybody thank you for joining me uh
tomorrow night 8pm eastern time i really
hope you will join me for the trump
rally in nebraska we've got a lot of
different things lined up if you don't
join me i'm basically a guy in a room
with a mic by myself and that it's gonna
be it's sad for everybody okay so please
join me tomorrow
and we'll see everybody then thank you